what we are arguing
is against the Western Mantra that
democracy is the right and appropriate
system for all countries whatever their
circumstances
after 1989 and the collapse of Soviet
communism
the Western Orthodoxy was that democracy
was the universal Panacea
first of all let's take Russia
there was a widespread expectation and
belief that Russia would develop a
western-style democracy and a
western-style free market
over the years it's become clear not
only is that not true but what we've
witnessed is the reassertion of Russian
history Russian traditions and Russian
culture and with that the emergence of
an authoritarian state